mike matt congratulations you've made it
to the next phase in this operation
which means we're sending you back to
your home for just to recreate this
iconic weapon
the united states air force
non-commissioned officer sword
you'll have four days at your home
forges in which to complete this
challenge at the end of four days you'll
return and present your swords to our
panel of expert judges and after they've
put them through the paces they'll move
one of you on to our final battle of the
branches competition
you also need to make a scavenge for
this sword man
i'm just messing with you good luck
blade smiths we'll see you in four days
good luck brother
it's day one it feels great to be back
here at my home forge for this blade i'm
gonna be using damascus and i'm gonna
try to put in a twist just for fun
a lot of air force ties in how i live my
life day to day and this challenge was
no exception
there's a lot of first for me on this
blade i've never done damascus this long
i've never heat treated anything this
long i've never made a cross guard like
this before it's going to be a bit
stressful for me none of my welds pop so
at least it's a solid billet
so we won't know for sure until we're
grinding into it
but i'm fairly certain it was a
successful twist
i don't think we have any inclusions
i think it's going to look pretty good
so i've got 16 layers now in this billet
i've got it drawn out enough i can cut
it into three sections stack it back on
itself for a total of 48 layers
this is gonna be one of the longest
things i've ever forged so keeping it
straight might be a little bit of a
challenge especially with the twist in
it that could cause some things to warp
all in all a solid finish for day one
now that i'm one of two airmen left
i definitely want to be you know the one
that shows that the air force has what
it takes to win the fortune fire branch
competition
the plan for today is to draw the 1084
round stock out
i'm just going to draw a little line on
the floor to give me an idea of how far
i'm drawing it out to start the 1084
steel was 20 inches i got to draw it out
to about 35 inches
to get the cross guard the handle and
the pommel on
i still got to draw it out quite a bit
down with this
27 to 28 inch sword it's gonna be
interesting keeping it straight
it is a negative 18 outside right now so
i'm ready to get inside and turn this
forge on
so yesterday i got the blade drawn out
this morning we're going for the flinch
getting something this long hot
and keeping it straight is uh going to
be one of my biggest challenges right
now
now i got a warping issue
i might be heat treating it again
in the back of your mind you're always
thinking did the heat treat not go well
quenching two times will i have you know
bad grain structure i have a ton of
concerns
slight warp but at this point
i'm definitely not quenching again
it's the morning of day four i didn't
sleep very well i still need to finish
the pommel i need to finish the cross
guard and i haven't even started the
handle yet
i can tell we're almost through though
almost there
i can feel it
i definitely think this is a blade
worthy of having me stand at the air
force angle in the final round
it is an example of how i problem solve
how i look for solutions and how i don't
give up
all right that's as good as we're gonna
get
day four and today i need to get the
cross guard fitted up the handle shape
wrapped with wire and then the palm will
assembled as well
holy handle looking at the original nco
sword i was trying to figure out what
the best way to make that wire wrapped
handle was safety wire we used that in
the military i thought that was good to
kind of throw a little air force ism
into it it works perfect i'm definitely
nervous that i have only one day left in
the back of your mind you're always
thinking do i have what it takes to move
on to the battle of branches i mean
that's what it's all about
that's it
may the best airmen win
all right airmen
now we'll take your weapon and deliver
some thrust and slashes on this
ballistics dummy
mike you're up first you ready
absolutely let's do it
[Music]
oh
all right mike
it's a very light sword because of that
you can move with it
now your tip allows for a nice thrust
with your edge it slices i can feel
every cut in there but more importantly
it will kill
thank you all right matt your turn you
ready sir yes sir
nice
all right matt's talk about your blade
here
the edge that you have here is very
sharp the point
punctures nicely and most importantly
sir
it'll kill awesome thank you
all right next up the strength test for
that we have ben
hello bladesmiths to test the strength
and durability of your swords as well as
their overall construction i'll be
bashing them into this propeller
mike you're up first you ready
no
we're gonna do it anyway all right
good job
well mike
your blade held up great the only issue
i have with it is that i would really
like this pommel to be bigger if the
pommel were bigger it would give me a
stop but it's got a nice weight
it's still sharp as when it started
really well done thank you so much
matt you're up what are you thinking
ready
so
badass
well matt your blade
held up great it's still sharp
this is a much heavier sword but the
biggest issue i have is with the cross
guard and back your cross guard is loose
it wiggles and also your wire wrap is
loose
but
it's all in one piece it did a heck of a
thing on that propeller well done thank
you when we're not finished yet next up
is the sharpness test and for that i
give you the doug
all right airmen to test the edge of
your blade i'm going to be cutting
across these harnesses
i'm looking for clean cuts
mike you're up first you ready for this
let's do it let's do this
good job you're good
sharp all right mike
light and flight and sharp enough to cut
through the harness it will cut thank
you sir good job thanks man
all right matt your turn sir you ready
yes sir
all right matt let's talk about your
blade here it's kind of heavy
it's so forward in its weight that on
this slash using the last six inches it
just scratched the back of the harness
but on the backhand swing where it's
going all the way through it cut the
harness
put your weapon sir it will cut thanks
good job man thanks
mike matt the blade smith moving forward
is
mike congratulations
thank you
matt first of all thank you for your
service you have a beautiful sword that
did quite well but we based our decision
on the fact that your guard came loose
the weight of your sword and the wire
wrapping is also loose well that's the
reason we're sending it home
yes sir
matt at this time i have to ask you to
please surrender your blade
i feel good no matter what i mean i'm
glad i made it here good job thank you
i'm proud of myself for sure
[Music]
mike's going to represent the air force
well he's got a lot of people rooting
for him me as well and he's a good
bladesmith so good luck
mike they said you're only as good as
your competition and you overcame a
fantastic competitor to move forward in
this competition to represent the entire
branch of the air force at our battle of
the branches competition how do you feel
feels amazing please present your blade
to the judges
i can't believe i'm the air force
champion i'm looking forward to showing
the rest of the dod what we've got
there's a lot of added pressure moving
forward now i'm competing against the
army the navy and the marine corps we've
got a little bit of a rivalry going on
so you better bring it because you know
i'm going to
you